and lastly the city of La is its own
character in the film which I love can
you tell me about your early memories of
La I think Chad for you I read that it
was a little bit lonely and beginning
you had a TV that had a couple channels
and no furniture and I can attest to
that I remember those days can you just
tell us an interesting story both of you
from early days in LA studio apartment I
had studio I had really nothing to my
name I never garbage can and I remember
that my buddy and I I mean we hung out
all the time we just said Starbucks I'm
into a Boulevard just talked about
acting life and love movies and things
like that till all hours in the morning
and then we come back to my place and we
had nothing to do so we just play um
video games little bubble bobble little
super Tecmo Bowl Holden pal games
because that's all I had was a Nintendo
I brought it with me from from from
Buffalo and I didn't have a table and
we're having a couple beers underage I'm
my dad and um we didn't have anything
but my VCR broke so I ripped the top off
of it and found that there was two
perfectly sized beer holders they were
just jam ran the electronics and boom I
had a beer holder it's fantastic that
was my coffee table that's awesome
should a pattern I should have i buy one
of those right see all right that'll be
insane literally just it's beer holder
for me I had a I moved to LA I had a
this really really dumpy apartment that
where I could see just from like one
corner right where I sort of set up my
computer I can see the Hollywood sign
but the problem was we're sort of near
the La Brea Tar Pits and the entire
apartment building smelled like sulfur
and I became immune to but every time I
would you know bring a friend over my
way at that time girlfriend now wife she
would be like not staying here so I
tried so that was kind of you know I had
a pretty miserable apartment cuz it
stank like eggs yeah is that where the
mud reference Cayman know the mud
reference came out of this you know
crazy mind of mine yeah and it's all
because of the soil because of the
sulfur what it did to my 88 away of my
mind